I have a friend going to Mexico because of a tumor. I realize in Mexico you can get treatments
You can't get it in the United States, but are the Mexico clinics helpful or of no value?
I think the Mexico clinics are great. So I would never bash another practitioner's clinic anyhow, but the truth is
These days you could probably get just about everything that you're getting in Mexico in the United States. So
I used to say that you couldn't, but that's not the case anymore. So
You might be able to get it less expensive, but that's not necessarily the case anymore either. So
I've had patients go down to so I don't know
Whoever's listed is might not know really what we do here, but
90% of
patients members in our clinic have cancer. So we're mainly an alternative cancer
We see autoimmune line patients and help with right frequencies and things
So we have had throughout the years our experience with lots of people that have gone to Mexico before they came to us or
went to Mexico concurrently
Let's see us at our advantage in their case too
A lot of people had great great
Experiences in Mexico, but over the years now things have loosened up in the United States
So a lot of things that were only available in Mexico are now available in the United States
And then fortunately the prices have gone up dramatically in Mexico used to be going down there
You could go there for three weeks and for $20,000 or something three weeks of
Care they did a bunch of different things to you well now you might spend 60 grand down there
So the prices have really really risen down there
So I don't see as much value in going down there as I if you would ask me that question 10 years ago
So but I mean they thought about it great about it investigated
They want to go to Mexico by all means certainly if they want every discussion with us
They can at the very least if you could point them to our website to give them some you know
So they could look at and see some of the things that we do
The only other thing I don't like about the Mexico clinics is some of them are
They were developed by okay the Hoxy clinic in Mexico
They were you know initially developed by Dr. Hoxy who was basically run out of Texas and
In the 1950s and went down there. So what do they offer at the Hoxy?
Well, we can get Hoxy here though, which is an herbal concoction
At the you know the
The clinic you know, so they're very specific to kind of their ancestry of the clinic of what they offer
so
There's that that's really